Oh with these lashes and this shirt cat
my jersey is like oozing out of me right
now no no no you know life is different
now so I'm still in full makeup from
shooting six episodes of this might get
a with mamrie Hart are Monday through
Friday show that we have on YouTube if
you haven't subscribed please subscribe
go check it out it's really fun it's not
the worst but maybe nice but a couple
things one we are both very lacking on
content on our channels to weigh over
makeup done
still today so 3 why don't we shoot some
videos with each other for our channel
so after hours of brainstorming we've
decided that we are gonna go meet at
Cheesecake Factory business meeting and
then we're gonna pop over to forever 21
and buy each other outfits that's a very
cool trendy fun thing here on YouTube I
watch a lot of people that do like my
mom buys my outfit my sister buys our
outfits stuff like that and I think
they're really fun but we're gonna
attempt to buy each other very cheap
thematic outfits I think like three or
four maybe two that's what the business
meeting at Cheesecake Factory is about
beforehand and we'll go from there in
the meantime let's get our PowerPoint
presentations ready and our briefcases
packed because we're going to our
favorite boardroom
[Music]
business meeting it started will they
become Samantha
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow worked up a full glow there they are
maybe and I finished shopping we've
decided on four categories of outfits
that we've purchased for each other two
will be featured on my channel to be
featured on hers I'm going to explain
this again in the future the initial
goal was to buy four outfits for each
other
totaling $100 altogether I might have
gone 60 dollars over budget if you know
me you know I don't like rules
samer definitely want maybe ten dollars
over let's find out we're here we did it
now I've kind of explained this but let
me now that we have fully had our
conference meeting our business meeting
about it I can fully explain it to you
maimry I went shopping for each other we
bought each other four different looks
have been to four different categories
those categories are barbecue also it's
the first time I've spoken on the vanity
on acai and it's like barbecue like
going to a cookout like some casual
you're gonna be outside all day you're
amongst friends you know everybody we're
doing a standard job interview outfit
also date night and the fourth category
is a wild card something completely
random that just doesn't fit into any
other categories on memories channel we
will be showing you our outfits for a
job interview and a first date and on
this channel we're gonna go through a
barbecue and a wild card also the other
parameters or that we were supposed to
spend 120 dollars in total on all four
looks give or take no you take and you
take and you take this [ __ ] is never
not gone over budget on anything I've
ever done I don't like rules I feel like
it's okay in this scenario to go over
budget because I'm fine super my friends
know it's true I mean it's fine if you
hit nails and die
it's all forever 21 30 bucks an outfit
yes let's do it at each other our first
category is barbecue so my outfit for
memory first of all it's already been
explained in memories video if you
haven't seen it already I got maybe one
pair of shoes for all four outfits
because we're on a budget and I got
these what I thought were classy and
also may be trendy cute white kitten
heels
memories responses bins you need to take
those kids to a kill shelter I took a
risk and didn't pay off my yard so this
is the foundation of your barbecue out I
totally always wear heels to barbecue if
you're gonna walk on grass you gotta
make sure you're sinking you got to wow
green pinstripe jumpsuit halters isn't
this cute dress jumpsuit sorry I think
in Palm Springs you're more likely to
wear this with just me I also my I got
it okay
maybe be like a Palm Springs each
scenario only going this somewhere that
has a polo match this is very southern
trauma but I think the green looks
really good with your eyes and your hair
color hmm I'm curious to see how this
pins out and then the other thing that
you can but I am sure you won't and you
don't have to do not the earrings she
got these earnestly I did because you
wanted both okay why maybe you wear
white boots that you bought up the
Amazon hi-hats mod 60s bill gets super
compliments on it that I thought maybe
this is also mod 60s kitten meow hmm
my god I was rushed I didn't make the
best decisions I'll admit it
no I'm doing great this could be cool
feel free to put a denim jacket with
everyone over this oh no I'm not helping
your look because I'm going back from a
look at my channel I'm doing the little
boot because it's steady footing I want
you and also you look really great with
like short with boots like your legs are
crazy and they accentuate a perfect
height boot it's not a flat it's not
full like four-inch heel exactly
and then we're going to have much
different barbecues oh no I got you some
really cute high-waisted pop shorts are
they cute it doesn't seem like they're
gonna be like thong underwear exactly
you know there's no ass cheeks hanging
out and then with the top I'm going
straight old school hello
oh yeah I got a little striped top
you're flipping burgers in these you
know what I mean you're not playing
croquet I'm like the Dennis the Menace
at the party and okay let's see how this
looks
look on reveal you look so cute don't
you but on one side be like half her
face is cut off yeah now our face is
Internet oh man we might not have a
business the whole first half so I'm
headed to the regatta
me too I thought it was when I first got
it but I think you can style this much
better than I did to make it very much
more main brain it's very classy like I
would definitely wear this to something
in Charleston oh yeah
only thing is I'd have to duct-tape my
titties but I also feel like this is a
very easy like bathing suit cover-up at
the same time I'm Josh I hate these kids
so much every day amazing I feel a
little cowboy well because of the boots
and the short but it was just as oh yeah
I think it looks really good I think so
great it's all stuff that I wear
together or separately so you nailed it
I have room for improvement yeah wow
that kitten heel really meow me okay
and now finally let's get to our
wildcard looks there is no rules for
this category based on how I've been
doing so far your video in mind you're
gonna hate what I got you I went so
different not so different but just
stuff that I don't think you would ever
like look at her body burn yours I was
just like I'm gonna get something that's
like cute I think she'll wear this you
might wait
I feel like you might wear these
separate I just thought why not give you
a loop and see what I knew we have cute
little rose gold I love a shell toad
sneak so cute love them then I did it's
so great oh my grandma shirt dress my
back cute as is and then I've gotten
really into adding a tube song I love
this so much so the tube sock matches
with the red so you've got the little to
top the little kicks and the little
dress and I thought this is good to be
an everyday look I love it so much
really good wild card thank you like
you'll wear it a lot
oh it's wonderful okay I'm like you and
you need top card is definitely a wild
but I hope you might appreciate the
separate pieces one unfortunately oh so
I went a little like sporty spice JLo
first of all we have to I like these a
lot
okay okay so these are sweatpants I have
all different flags on the side of them
you know how cultured I am right with
the kitten heel great with a kitten heel
as I thought very sporty spice means
Victoria Beckham so these I thought
could be find you can wear them with or
without the rest of this outfit I got I
think this is a fun shirt it's just a
striped reckless service at your service
okay which is stupid but I think it's
fun and you can like tie it up this like
a lounge a weird tonight to watch The
Bachelorette and then this actually I
got to go with every outfit because you
need bag to hold your head into it so I
got you this bag which is basically it's
a fanny pack you can also take the fanny
part out and have it as a clutch I dig a
fanny pack right so the belt situation
so your hands are free and then you also
if you don't want a fanny pack situation
you can take the belt part out and just
hold it as a club I always want to panic
I wore a fanny pack for July 4th and
like I thought I lost my first eight
hundred charge okay I'm taking this
wildcard outfit a lot favored kitten
heels well let's see what they look like
goody uh-huh and open
oh that looks [ __ ] great
oh I should be dating a botanist you
gotta put your gold earrings on with
this that's the one thing that's missing
is giant hoop earrings I should be doing
this a lot love the fanny pack I will
admit it's my new favorite purse I will
wear these all the friggin time know if
this is something I'd wear in public
but let's keep together this is like
you're at home you're compatible but
you're fashionable enough that you're
gonna Instagram story say on your couch
nailed it I love this this is very very
me it's very much like little girl meets
adult woman yes I know it's pretty
Spears I'm not a girl not get a woman
exactly and also I've been experimenting
with a higher crew sock it's fun it's
fun very like tomboy but still feminine
in some bizarre world in a weird strange
universe or and so sort of team and I'm
your coach right now oh my god I feel
like we're at some bizarre pageant and
you're my mama Tara and I'm like you
gotta wipe your nose the Fashion Show at
the end of don't come on the babysitter
sexy if you were this with the sneakers
that you got me and the gold hoops that
you got me I feel like I would be a flow
lose but no one works with me I mean I
love this I'm jelly there she don't be
jelly you can borrow it while you gonna
return my other stuff
okay guys what did you think of those
outfit so we obviously have clear
opinions about them but let me know in
the comments down below what you love
but you hated what you did you know I'm
about and you go check memories channel
for the other two outfits that we bought
each other and let us know over there
what you bought and don't forget one to
watch this might get which is Monday
through Friday on YouTube and two to
never buy kit meals
yeah yeah if there's any lesson we take
away from both of these videos is that
case are wrong
I don't know Flo Luke he's like we're
taking you're saying the name Luke and
I'm like oh no Luke le wk oh yeah Luke
I'm like Wilson
yeah Luke Wilson is a fashion I